>>> WANT TO BRING BACK OUR ;
a
ANALYSIS ON THE BREAKING NEWS
WE'RE FOLLOWING NOW.
RON DeSANTIS OFFICIALLY PUBLICLY
LAUNCHING HIS CAMPAIGN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES ;
a
.
I UNDERSTAND THEY'VE GOT SOME
PROBLEMS OVER THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> YEAH, THIS WAS A CONCERN SOM;
a
G
TON A CONVERSATION SOMEONE HAS.;
a
CLEARLY I'M NOT SURE IF THEY ;
WOULD BE LISTENING OR TRYING TO
JOIN.
OBVIOUSLY QUITE A AUDIENCE ON
THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF GLITCHING THAT;
a
.
TO THIS
IT'S NOT CLEAR IF IT'S FULLY ;
a
.
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO SO A FEW;
a
YOU HEARD ELON MUSK BRIEFLY
SPEAKING ON THIS, BUT IT KEPT
CRASHING AND DROPPING.
THI
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS A
POTENTIAL TO HAPPEN.
OBVIOUSLY TWITTER HAS NOT BEEN
RUNNING SMOOTHLY AS YOU'VE SEEN;
a
EVEN THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN
MOCKING IT ALREADY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SENDING OUT A
TWEET SAYING THIS LINK WORKS.;
a
IT'S A LINK TO FUND RAISE FOR ;
.
DeSANTIS CAMPAIGN LAUNCH AND ;
a
JUST HOW GLITCHY IT IS.
NOT OFF TO A SMOOTH START.
THIS IS THE CONCERN OF COURSE ;
a
THOSE SIMILAR TRADITIONAL ;
DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE LIKE THIS, ;
a
BUT THIS IS HOW THE DeSANTIS ;
STARTED
WHERE THEY'RE HAVING NOT A VERY
CONTROLLED ISSUE AND ELON MUSK
KEEPS TALKING ABOUT HOW MANY ;
a
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO LISTEN.;
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THEY ;
a
LISTENED TO CAMPAIGN LAUNCH AND;
CLEARLY IT'S HAVING A LOT OF ;
a
.
I DON'T EVEN THINK IT'S
HAPPENING.
>> IT'S VERY AWKWARD.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO START ABOUT
20 MINUTES OR SO AGO.
HASN'T STARTED YET.
SARAH, YOU'RE OUR SOCIAL MEDIA ;
a
YOU'RE AN EXPERT IN THIS AREA.;
.
>> I WAS IN THAT AUDIO SPACE AND
WHEN I JOINED, THERE WERE ABOUT;
a
667,000 PEOPLE TRYING TO LISTEN;
TWITTER HAS HELD MUCH BIGGER
EVENTS.
WHEN ELON DID HIS BBC INTERVIEW;
a
I THINK THEY DIDN'T ANTICIPATE
WAS THAT MANY PEOPLE COMING IN ;
a
AT THE SAME TIME.
BECAUSE THEY SAID IT WOULD STAR;
a
TRYING TO LISTEN TO THIS.
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHEN YO;
a
.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA, I'M ON MY PHONE
NOW.
IT CAN BE IN STREECAMING.
IT'S THE HUGE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE ;
a
THAT OFTEN MESSES THIS UP.;
BYPASS THE TRADITIONAL MEDIA.
GO DIRECT TO MY LISTENERS.;
a
TRY TO DO THAT IN LAUNCHING YOU;
CAMPAIGN, IT DOESN'T WORK AND ;
a
YOU'RE ALMOST A HALF HOUR LATE
TO YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> THIS IS CLEARLY NOT THE
ROLLOUT THAT DeSANTIS AND HIS ;
a
?
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
BUT I MEAN, I THINK WE HAVE TO ;
a
PRETTY PREDICTABLE.
THE CHALLENGE WITH DOING AN ;
a
TRYING TO PRESENT AN IMAGE OF A;
RUNNING EVENT, WHICH IS A ;
a
MICROCOSM OF A SMOOTH RUNNING ;
CAMPAIGN, DOING IT IN THIS
FORMAT INTRODUCED A HUGE AMOUNT
OF RISK
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS THAT ;
a
RON DeSANTIS IS RUNNING ON AND ;
HOW HE'S RUNNING, WHAT HIS ;
a
CAMPAIGN LOOKS LIKE, PEOPLE ARE;
.
THERE'S SUCH A THING AS NEGATIV;
a
ATTENTION AND RIGHT NOW, GETTING
A LOT OF NEGATIVE ATTENTION AND;
a
AND IT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO ;
BE UNDONE BY ANYTHING THAT IS
SAID LATER TONIGHT IN A MORE
TRADITIONAL FORMAT.
FIRST IMPRESSIONS MATTER A LOT ;
a
.
I THINK HE IS LEARNING A REALLY
IMPORTANT LESSON RIGHT NOW THAT
YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO;
a
HAVE TO HAVE YOUR DUCKS IN A ROW
AND UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS ;
a
.
PEOPLE.
WHEN I CHECKED A COUPLE OF
MINUTES AGO, IT WAS ABOUT
300,000.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LEAVING.
MAYBE THEY'RE BEING KICKED OUT
BECAUSE OF TECHNICAL GLITCHES.